and just let me know when you want me to
oh okay all right hello
it gives me great pleasure to introduce
Louise Barnett historian professor of
English at Rutgers University author of
the biography of George Armstrong Custer
and today she will be discussing her new
book ungentlemanly acts Louise thank you
the subtitle of my book is the Army's
notorious incest trial this trial took
place in 1879 probably scandalous incest
trial would have been more accurate
because the army was very interested in
keeping this trial a secret
there wasn't any publicity the
court-martial proceedings were private
and it was really a scandalous subject
the first trial that we have in American
history that very explicitly discusses
the subject of incest here's what
happened a young army captain Andrew
Geddes 34 years old was stationed in the
remote Texas frontier post of Fort
Stockton located in the West Texas
desert very remote in those days from
other places he ultimately produced an
affidavit about what he saw one night
early in March he shared officer's
quarters that has had quarters in the
same building with a lieutenant Lewis or
woman a man 38 years old who was living
in these quarters with his 18 year old
daughter Lily and no one else the two
shared a bedroom the internal wall
separated the get us in or woman
quarters and through that wall light one
night
captain Geddes said that he heard Lily
or lemon say Papa
please don't captain Geddes will hear us
well having heard that captain Geddes
went outside and looked in the bedroom
window of lieutenant or lemons quarters
and said that he saw the lieutenant and
his daughter engaged in what at that
time was called criminal intercourse the
next morning he continued to say he
confronted lily or lemon and she broke
down and admitted to him that her father
had been using her in this manner for
five years every time she tried to end
the relationship in which she felt
imprisoned her father threatened to kill
her or kill himself or desert the family
which consisted of a wife and seven
younger children living in Austin Texas
and at that time women had few
opportunities to work if the father had
abandoned the family they would have
been forced into a state of destitution
so Lily felt very trapped she saw and
captain get us this young handsome
officer a possible Savior he was very
sympathetic wanted to help her and they
made plans for him to take her away
return her to her mother's house in
Austin however it seems to me that
lieutenant or lemon was perhaps the
smartest and shrewdest person in this
situation and he realized once captain
get us confronted him and said that he
was going to remove Lily from his
clutches that if he preferred charges
against captain Geddes he would have the
upper hand in other words he made a
preemptive strike by going to the
commanding officer Fort Stockton and
saying that captain Geddes was planning
to seduce and abduct his daughter and
would make the slanderous accusation of
incest against him so captain Geddes was
suddenly put on the defensive and he
went to the departmental commander Jen
Oh Lord in San Antonio and submitted
this affidavit his side of the story
lieutenant olam clearly had coerced his
daughter to repudiate what she had told
captain get us general orde as commander
of the department had great power over
the course of events he could decide to
bring charges against lieutenant or
woman for incest he could decide to
bring charges against captain Geddes for
conduct unbecoming he could decide to
settle the whole thing in-house without
having any court-martial proceedings it
was up to him well at this point when I
tell people that an officer was tried
sentenced his career ruined
they always assumed that it was the
guilty party the man who committed
incest this is not what happened however
general Ord decided to court-martial
captain Geddes he was brought to trial
found guilty of conduct unbecoming
dismissed from the Army how could such a
situation happen why given the evidence
and it turned out that there was not
only captain Geddes a--'s Word but there
was corroborating evidence that
lieutenant
Orla man was guilty so why did General
Order decide to pursue the man who
simply brought the situation to the
attention of the authorities rather than
a man who possibly had committed a very
serious crime I think there are a number
of answers to this question we have to
remember that in 1879 we're in the
period of Victorian America in which
incest is a deep taboo perhaps the
deepest people were not supposed to even
think about it they weren't supposed to
talk about it
it was worse it turns out to talk about
it then to do it
this is the moral of what happened to
the parties involved but I should stop
here and say tell you why I'm convinced
that lieutenant Orel Minh was absolutely
guilty as captain Geddes had said not
only were there witnesses who had
observed similar behavior on the part of
of lieutenant or woman but Lily or woman
had written notes to captain get us
which he kept and these notes
it seems to me make it crystal clear
that the subject under discussion was
incest and not something lesser they
tend to say things like please don't
tell anyone my father's secret please
swear that you won't tell anyone
if you did it would be the end of his
family he said that he's going crazy
please swear that you won't tell during
the trial
Lily or woman was unable to give a
persuasive explanation of the series of
notes there's also something else
every officer had a soldier who was
required to keep his quarters clean and
so on and the particular soldier is
dying too lieutenant
tenant or Lemmons quarters would have
testified that on many occasions only
one bed had been slept in and that on
one particular occasion he knocked on
the bedroom door heard no answer and
opened the door and found lieutenant or
woman his daughter in the same bed in
some state of disarray
however this witness was not cold the
reason being that in the military code
of justice at that time the prosecutor
the judge advocate as he was called in
those days had total control of what
witnesses the defense was allowed to
summons and this particular judge
advocate who was clearly very ambitious
and zealous prosecutor denied the
defense the opportunity of calling the
soldier whose
testimony certainly would have
substantiated
Captain Geddes accusation there were
other witnesses who had seen lieutenant
or lemon fondle the breasts of his
daughter and kiss her passionately take
him on take her on his lap and fondle
her and in a manner that was not
appropriate for a father and daughter so
you also have to ask yourself why
Captain Geddes would have made up such
an appalling story if whatever his
motives might have been in fact when the
Judge Advocate General the Army's the
highest military judicial officer
reviewed the transcript of the trial
incident we were talking about six
hundred handwritten pages of the trial
record plus exhibits the Judge Advocate
General reviewed this very thoroughly
and said that he believed that the
Orleans were guilty he also found many
prejudicial errors of procedure in the
trial and throughout the verdict it's at
this point that General of the army
William Tecumseh Sherman gets interested
in the proceedings and his position
first of all his general position was
that military justice had to be harder
than civilian justice that civilian
justice was often soft it let people off
too easily the military because it was a
code applying to warriors should not do
this and in the Geddes case he made it
clear what he was willing to do to find
someone to find the accused guilty when
the verdict was thrown out and I must
say that the Judge Advocate General
prepared a very lengthy and I think
compelling document but it's not clear
the Chairman even read it he rushed
ahead to find a way to try get us again
on other charges to get
out of the army he didn't even consider
for a moment that or woman might be
guilty he said we've got to remove this
monster captain get us from the Army
here too I'd like to mention that
captain Geddes had an excellent field
record he was thought of very highly by
fellow officers who signed a petition
supporting him during the original trial
however he had a weakness that enabled
the army to pursue him he had been a
womanizer he had been a careful
womanizer his targets had been the
dissatisfied wives of other officers and
I think the place where he made a
serious error was that one of these
wives was the wife of the commander of
Fort Stockton and apparently this was so
scandalous that she gave birth to a
child fathered by Captain Geddes her
husband just owned her but did not
divorce her he simply sent her back to
her relatives this is what you did at
the time under such circumstances but
that commanding officer general Napoleon
Bonaparte McLaughlin was very highly
regarded in the department of Texas the
army the frontier army at that time was
a very small group everybody knew
everyone else and you can imagine that
this episode was a real scandal and that
people many people who liked mcLaughlin
were not happy about Geddes role in it
in any case
General Sherman dispatched an assistant
inspector general to go to Texas and dig
up dirt on get us so that he could be
tried on other charges there are a
couple of ironies about this as I read
the case first of all Sherman makes a
big point in his correspondence on the
trial about how the proper gentleman
must protect the reputation
of ladies it's up to him to protect
these ladies nevertheless if Sherman had
gone ahead to a trial of get us on the
kinds of charges he was digging up
evidence on the reputation of a number
of ladies would have been severely
damaged and yet it didn't matter to him
in fact I see this trial in terms of men
sacrificing women to their own interests
for example lieutenant or woman had been
exonerated by the army even before the
trial he really didn't have to have this
court-martial to get the Army's approval
so he dragged his daughter through this
very painful procedure in which she had
to submit to repeated gynecological
examinations as well as testified to
this all-male tribunal simply so that he
could emerge victorious in any case
before Sherman completed his plans to
retry get us plans which incidentally
the Judge Advocate General tried to
dissuade him from because a lot of it
was simply gossip and hearsay rather
than hard and fast evidence that would
stand up in a court it was possible to
try get us on other charges and get him
out of the army he was brought up on a
charge of drunk on duty it's very clear
from the transcript of that trial that
he was taken sick while he was at parade
he immediately turned over the his
duties to another officer and left the
parade grand a doctor confirmed that he
was genuinely sick but it was enough for
the army to get rid of him and clearly
was a real kangaroo court he was
dismissed his military service his
career was over much to his distress I
think this trial also ruined the life of
Lily or woman
did not marry until she was over 60 when
she married a widower had a brief
marriage until his death the only person
who came out on top was the man who
committed incest lieutenant or woman
retired from active duty but had a long
career afterwards as an instructor in a
military academy live to the ripe old
age of 94 now there's a little addendum
to this story that I at least find
interesting when my book was finished
but not yet
out it was listed on amazon.com is
forthcoming and because of this I
received an email from a woman who
identified herself as a
great-granddaughter of this lieutenant
or woman and she had been going to check
check out books on amazon.com to see the
listing for her own book which happens
to be an incest survivors memoir she had
known nothing about this earlier
instance in the family it had clearly
been a skeleton in the closet that no
one had talked about but she was simply
bowled over to find out that in an
earlier generation someone had suffered
the same thing that she had suffered and
needless to say I was rather chilled to
find out that the same behavior had
occurred in a later generation of the
family well I've talked a while maybe
someone has a question that they can ask
about this is the thing is like a soap
opera it's a very complex trial with all
kinds of issues having to do with women
and race comes into it too because these
were black troops who were officers by
whites stationed at Fort Stockton
I'd like to ask um how did you first
become interested in the subject well
this is a good question since I've been
identified as an English professor I
always have to explain what I'm doing
writing history I worked in my field of
specialization American literature and
culture for 20-some years and I think
probably at the time I became interested
in history I was in need of a change
something related but at the same time
different and what got me started was a
visit to the Little Bighorn Battlefield
that was a turning point I decided to
write about George Armstrong Custer and
I just plunged into the subject at the
battlefield archive and elsewhere and
wrote a book called touched by fire the
life death and mythic afterlife of
George Armstrong Custer which
incidentally won a prize the year it was
published as the best book in its field
that the Little Bighorn Associates gives
in that that area I'm very pleased with
that book in connection with my custard
work I had to look at some army
courts-martial involving Custer and
officers in his regiment and I found
these trials to be fascinating they
weren't on particularly sensationalistic
topics but just the whole mechanism of
the trial the inherent drama in any
trial got me hooked on the subject so I
started reading around in army
courts-martial and just like the
civilian justice system the military has
to deal with all kinds of issues not
simply things like desertion going AWOL
drunkenness on-duty although those are
very popular charges but murder rape
every every possible crime that people
are capable of committing
we'll turn up in military trials just as
they do in the civilian judicial system
so I found these trials very engrossing
and at a certain point another
researcher said to me well maybe you'd
like to read the trial of Andrew Gatos
so I got this heavy book 600 handwritten
pages opened it up started reading and
literally could not put it down i I just
remain glued to that text in the
National Archives reading room it seemed
as if one one thing was more fascinating
than another and I'll tell you one of
the most amazing and interesting aspects
of it was all of the testimony on
virginity again keeping in mind that at
this time people did not talk about such
things there they didn't talk about
anything having to do with sex or the
body much less incest but it was
necessary to explore the issue of
whether this 18 year old girl had indeed
had sexual experience too to talk about
her virginity one doctor examined her
and for me the chilling thing about his
testimony is that it's full of
inaccuracy the reason being that at that
time women did not routinely have
gynecological examinations they only had
examinations in connection with
childbirth or some terrible problem it
just wasn't done so most doctors had
very little experience with a a virginal
woman or a woman who had sexual
experience but had not become pregnant
I'm not going to go into all of these
gory details I was sitting there reading
sometimes finding myself just completely
repulsed by what I was reading but for
example this doctor testified that of
course Lily or woman was a virgin
because
her nipples were still virginal well I'm
sure most of you know that the changes
that take place in woman's breasts occur
as a result of pregnancy and then more
as a result of childbirth but they do
not change the result of just plain
sexual experience the doctor also said
that his examination of lily hurt Lily's
genitals indicated that she had not had
sexual experience well he simply tried
to examine her manually and I'm sure she
had been coached to say of you're
hurting me please stop the minute he
approached the area and being a good
Victorian gentleman he wouldn't have
tried to pursue this then the defense
because the prosecution and testified
that Lily had not had sexual experience
they had to counter this by bringing in
like a half dozen doctors all of whom
talked about virginity and here the part
that's interesting is that this all-male
Court which in general in court-martial
and the court-martial a procedure the
jury the members of the court don't ask
a lot of questions they leave that up to
the judge advocate well suddenly this
court comes alive and everybody is
asking questions about virginity even
though a lot of the questions had very
little to do with the actual case it's
as if suddenly it was acceptable within
this framework to to find out anything
that they could about this important
issue so that's that gives us I think a
very interesting picture of how people
thought about sexuality at the time and
about women and incidentally although
this is the military trial it seems to
me what we're dealing with is simply the
way society was at the time it would
have been very similar in terms of the
emotions aroused and the attitude
express'd if it had been a civilian
trial what makes it a particularly
military of course in addition to the
fact that these men were officers is the
procedure of the military court I've
already mentioned that the Judge
Advocate could veto defense witnesses
which could be a terrible handicap
obviously to mounting a vigorous defense
in addition something that strikes me
about military procedure at the time in
trials as being very significant is the
fact that the judge advocate the
prosecutor deliberate with the jury with
the court now think of the tremendous
advantage that is you know he gets to he
doesn't even have to give a closing
statement because he's going to be
meeting with them and if they have any
questions he'll answer them according to
his point of view which is the site of
of finding captain Geddes guilty so
incidentally in case you're wondering
the system has been reformed since that
time the military the uniformed military
code of the military code uniform
justice in 1950 has changed that so that
those practices that would seem to us
particularly unfair today no longer
exist in the the court-martial procedure
than quite often because of the court
procedures at that time do you think
cases like that happened often that
innocent people were convicted or you
know similar cases to this and they just
were kept secret it's hard to say um
when you read a trial transcript you're
only getting the tip of the iceberg very
often you know all you have is the court
record and often you can't get further
information about what the real story is
for example nothing about major
McLaughlin wife and her affair with
Captain Geddes comes out in the trial I
was able to get that from other sources
but often you don't have this kind of
secret information I think probably most
courts-martial were fair for example
people who deserted and were captured
and brought back and tried for desertion
it's pretty open-and-shut and I've read
a lot of these cases and by and large
they're fair but this was an exceptional
situation first of all you know the
subject was unheard of and I would say
that any institution whether it's the
military or a large corporation or some
other branch of government does not want
unfavorable publicity the army had a
stake in keeping this accusation down in
in finding in choosing between Geddes
and Orel Minh you were choosing between
a pretty standard kind of charge namely
here's a young officer who's trying to
seduce a young woman that's you know not
right but it's nothing to to cause
people to get too surprised by on the
other hand the idea that a man is
committing incest with his daughter an
officer of the army clearly this is
ungentlemanly behavior that would have
been very bad publicity
for the army so I can really understand
the institutional desire to keep down
this publicity and ultimately to make a
choice between the career of this one
man and the greater good of the entire
organization however I don't see that
choice really being made it seems to me
it's more insidious or more subtle than
that it seems to me that everybody from
Sherman on down in the military
hierarchy was completely convinced that
Andrew Geddes was lying about lieutenant
or woman and to me what this says is
that at that time in our society people
just could not entertain the idea of
something as horrible as incest they
wanted to believe it could never happen
it didn't happen that anyone who talked
about it was some sort of degenerate
himself otherwise he wouldn't be talking
about it and that that was the attitude
that ultimately did in Captain get us
when he tried to be a good Samaritan and
rescue this young woman of course I
haven't told you all of the details that
are in the book but there is so much
that substantiates the guilt of
lieutenant or woman all of the
information that get us said that Lily
had told him it's just the kind of stuff
you can't imagine he would make up that
having to do with for example her aunt
from Germany had come and discovered
that this was happening
unless Lily had told him that there's no
way that captain get us could have known
it so I've been completely convinced on
the basis of my research that in fact
this was a terrible miscarriage of
justice the thing that's important to me
as a historian is to understand why
things like this happen
what very specifically happened to have
it'd have to get us
well when he was found guilty he was
sentenced to prison and dismissal that
verdict was thrown out and so he was
restored to his regimen
however because the army was very
determined to get rid of him
what happened immediately is that when
he went back to his regiment at Fort
Stockton his company was ordered to
leave for it Stockton and go to an even
more remote place in the desert where
there was nothing and to do field
service there so in essence he was
imprisoned in the West Texas desert
while they tried to figure out how to
get rid of him permanently not only was
he imprisoned but all the innocent men
who served under him were forced to go
out to this station
there's nowhere place while the army
figured out a way of dealing with it
ultimately his regiment was transferred
to North Dakota and it was there that
and his company was the last to make
this transfers as the army was trying to
get rid of him before they had to bring
him back to regimental life they weren't
able to move that quickly but he had
been in Dakota I think only a month or
so when these trumped-up charges of
drunk on duty were were made and he was
then dismissed he liked many officers
who were cashiered he kept trying to get
back into the military the only way you
could do this at the time was through an
act of Congress but since everything was
very political people did get back in by
getting powerful congressmen to to go to
bat for them he tried that but because
the army was so resistant and he never
saw the documents that this supposedly
fact-finding detective work had had
turned up it kept being turned down and
he didn't know why ultimately around
1900 he's already in his fifties it is
reversed
and he's given a proper military
discharge and is able to collect his
pension but he's never able to go back
to serving in the Army as he would have
liked he got some kind of low-grade job
in the Department of Agriculture
probably through influence he was from
Iowa he was connected with people who
had credentials there so he got this
bureaucratic job and clearly was not
very happy with it lived the rest of his
life in Washington DC you know what can
I say yes well today most of our
military court marshals are heavily
covered by the press I'm just curious I
know the subject is taboo at this time
and they're in a remote location where
the president ever involved in covering
this case after the case was decided the
Gettys ever go to the press no probably
because he felt it was in his best
interest to try to work within the
system particularly because he was
immediately reinstated and I think he
naively thought that was the end of it
and as far as I know he never went to
the press because he kept working to try
to get back into the army and that
certainly would have been fatal I don't
know how this was kept from the press
except for the fact that there's such a
taboo against incest that it's like that
time that some of us can remember when
the press did not report on the
extracurricular activities of
politicians there was just an unspoken
agreement nothing appeared on San
Antonio where the trial took place was
not that much of a backwater it was at
that time the largest city and the
center of the military department of
Texas nevertheless nothing appeared in
the newspapers
the San Antonio newspapers and there was
a little tiny reference to the trial in
the Army and Navy journal but it was it
just said the the subject matter of the
trial was so vulgar
it couldn't be talked about and in fact
when the army published its abstract of
the trial there was always a printed
abstract that told the basic findings of
a court-martial under these
specifications where they usually say
precisely what happened
it said not fit to be specified that was
the original title of my book which the
editor changed but I was really struck
by that because ordinarily in a
court-martial you have the charge
conduct unbecoming an officer and a
gentleman
and then the specification is on
such-and-such a date this is what he did
that was conduct unbecoming and they
weren't even going to put in print what
he did so society at that time was just
not ready to deal with an incendiary
subject like incest and I think one of
the reasons why I wanted to show this
photo if you can see it of this is
general the Civil War general Ord and
his wife and at that time nine-year-old
daughter and if you'll notice general
orden his daughter form one unit on one
side of the table
mrs. Ord is on the other and the
daughter and Ord at the time of the
trial had this daughter who was the
apple of his eye she was then about the
age of Lily or woman so he could relate
very strongly as a father she's leaning
against him you know in a pose that if
she were older would be seductive I mean
even notice that one shoulder is bare in
the picture now interestingly enough in
the trial testimony there's a very
similar theme reported with lieutenant
or lemon and his daughter in an army
ambulance that's taking them from Fort
Stockton to Fort Davis which was the
day's journey
Lily evidently leaned against her
father's shoulder and he put his arm
around her and it was at this time that
other occupants of the
ambulance noticed that he was actually
touching her breast which one of the
fascinating things to me about this is
that although no one knows anything
scientific about incest at the time it's
not mentioned it's not talked about
people weren't even supposed to think
about it all of the behavior of
lieutenant or woman falls into a very
classic pattern of the incest father as
we've come to know of him in research
that started in the 1970s for example he
was a German immigrant who came from a
much more strongly patriarchal culture
than existed in America at that time and
the incest father often feels very
possessive towards his daughter and I
think when lieutenant or woman is
recklessly we might say putting his hand
on Lily's breast in front of other
people he's asserting his ownership of
her there's another witness who
testified that he overheard a
conversation in which lieutenant or
woman was reproaching Lily with having
had relations with some younger officers
which as far as we know she hadn't done
and again it's like a kind of jealousy
you belong to me you know I'm not going
to let you have a boyfriend which in
fact Lily said during the trial that she
and her father had had an argument about
her getting attentions from younger
officers also incest families tend to be
ones with large numbers of children in
which the wife has a somewhat doesn't
have any authority and that would really
apply to the oralin family as well so I
think there's just everything says to me
that this was an actual case of of
incest
any more questions we finished ready for
signing sure thank you very much
one last thing people often ask me if
this could happen today and I certainly
hope it couldn't that you know the the
military has had trials of sexual
harassment my feeling is that they would
not be as squeamish now about such a
things I don't think you know which is
good news